Hey, remember me?
I was just wondering if you wanted to get maybe... dinner?
I don't know about you, but I love seafood.
There's a place on Wilshire
Well, we could... tonight?
Holly, right?
Holly Garling
Yes, Eric?
Hey Babe
I'm serious though Hol,
move on already!
Someone's popular
Who's the guy?
I already... Sorta have a boyfriend, so-
No you don't.
*Screams*
*Water drips*
All these people who talk about love like it's this... lightning bolt.
Loves not a lightning bolt.
Real love... takes work.
Are you really going to lecture me on love? You're keeping a girl in a cage.
I'm not doing this for me,
I'm doing this for you
No! Stop! Stop! Stop!
You just have it all figured out, don't you?
Seth's got a little crush.
You don't notice how lonely you really are.
This isn't about us.
I'm trying to save you.
Then do it... save me.